raise your hand if you've seen a rat or
a mouse in this club in the school we're
in Detroit where they say the city's
making a comeback after filing for
bankruptcy in 2013 but the public school
system is still in major crisis we're
talking underperforming and crumbling
schools and 3.5 billion dollars in debt
after fed up teachers began sharing
these photos on social media
the state-appointed emergency manager
who was running the district stepped
down and by the way that emergency
manager Darnell early is the same guy
who's being blamed for Flint's water
crisis so I saw the viral video that you
guys put out of all the problems in this
school it's raining and snowing right
inside of the school and it has created
these large pumps in the floor literally
all they're limited to is walking the
hall in addition to structural damage we
are missing an integral piece to our
staffing because we can't offer the type
of programming that we say we do this is
a performing arts school and we don't
have any performing arts teacher except
for vocal music this is our dance skills
as you can see I'm it is very nice
however we don't have a dance teacher
and so this young lady she volunteers
her time after school to come in and
teach our students to dance and if you
know
here about really how we feel
Michelle you grew up in the school year
in the eighth grade now what are some of
the things you've seen that you don't
necessarily love the jam falling apart
like it is
the ceilings
another huge up there I just didn't
expect all that to happen so this has
been going on for years this is not
something that just happened they just
refused to do the repairs because what
they call a lack of funding how
frustrating is that for you as a mother
when you see that your your your child
is in a school less than ideal condition
this is extremely frustrating especially
when I'm a hands-on parent so there are
people who look at what's happening in
Detroit with the public school system
and what's happening in Flint with the
water crisis and they think these are
two majority black cities in a majority
white state what's going on there what
do you think and let's say environmental
and educational racism what do you want
to be when you grow up attack gonna be a
doctor too how about you
you live in Belize okay so I'm going to
introduce you to this amazing family so
that on the road early this morning
three five this morning to bring school
supplies to Spain school you guys drove
eight hours here from Iowa yeah probably
why everybody else I mean we saw the
video and then you look up the situation
and nobody seems to be talking about the
kids are all talking about everything
but
so we just my wife and my cousin got on
Facebook and we're like we can study
bucks from all of our friends you bring
up a little column and so we all went
out and collected the books and school
supplies and all sorts of stuff but what
still remains is a lot of structural
damage
we need windows and doors we need
computers and we need textbooks still
and we need that we need humans to
actually apply and become employees of
Detroit Public Schools to teach and to
work with our students that's what we
really need is there an incentive for
them to do that I hate to say no
analysis no monetary incentive the
incentive would be the children